I said okay sing it in front of me okay
sing it in front of me in your mom okay
sing it in front of me and the rest of
the family okay sing it in front of me
and the family and the neighbors I hope
I stayed a little softer for a
glass-like sing it sing it you can
follow our next guest of course at Jocko
willing his website is Jocko podcast com
it's an incredibly popular podcast last
time he was when we talked about extreme
ownership but would Jesus co-author his
newest book I want to make sure I get it
is the dichotomy of leadership he was a
lieutenant commander of the US Navy
SEALs I mean the guy is just you
probably know who is Jack oh thanks for
being back sir appreciate it
I am glue this look at this this is a
our newest employee actually smooth mani
is a huge fan of yours so I'll have some
questions from him but he I went in just
the other day and saw just a stack of
these and I said is that Mona's desk
yeah that is that this Jacko celty said
oh yeah it's a whole story because he
doesn't drink coffee and so now I why
don't you tell it to the audience I
guess who doesn't because I was entirely
unfamiliar with this for my apologies so
I guess maybe I'm a bad person because
I'm super particular about things in the
world and the way I like things and so I
used to like to drink pomegranate tea
pomegranate white tea as a matter of
fact I don't know why somebody gave it
to me at some point I really like the
way it tastes it's God doesn't have a
ton of caffeine in it so so it doesn't
make you all jittery yeah anyways
eventually when I when I was on Tim
Ferriss podcast and we were drinking
pomegranate white tea and so people kept
asking what kind you drink what kind
what kind is it and I didn't really like
any particular brand because they were
all a little bit different and I didn't
really love any of them so I just made
one that I really really liked and put
it out there and people started buying
it and then from there I put it in cans
because you know sometimes it's kind of
a pain to do the whole heating up water
or putting a bag yeah I've tied that guy
what was the 10th person is 4-hour
workweek yeah so so I put it a can and
and then I kind of did that with a bunch
of other sort of supplements you know
like I like I like I like to be able to
drink protein but all the protein shakes
were always tasted horrible I had a
bunch of junket on so I made you know
a really good protein that tastes great
and all that stuff so that's just kind
of a little something that I do
unfortunately out like I said I'm I'm
probably too particular about things I
only like them the way I like them and
so I end up having to make what I want
and put it out there well you know it's
okay so that takes me to an interesting
interesting point because you are
particular I have been described as that
myself you know we're about to cross
three million subscribers on YouTube are
incredibly grateful for every single
year or listener means a lot I you know
you can either exalt yourself really
feel humbled by people who enjoy the
show I don't know your podcast just
completely exploded it's wildly popular
I recommend everybody check it out but
you are particular I'm kind of that way
as well how do you balance being
particular getting things right you know
with not being a dick well this is sort
of what the new book the dichotomy of
leadership is about you know nicely done
nicely done it doesn't say Glee because
I can see why you have so many
[Laughter]
incredible sarcasm detector it's a skill
like anything else but okay yes I is a
genuine question though I'm sure you've
it's you have different sometimes
different types of people and especially
as you lead people you learn this
different personalities have different
inner conflict so I'd imagine that's one
that people like you myself
smooth Manny share in common type-a
personalities yeah so one of the things
I think you gotta watch out for is what
matters and what doesn't matter well
like if you get wrapped around here
particular about things but your
particular about things that don't
matter and you let those things drive
you crazy or they you let those things
drive a wedge between you and your team
because you want things done a certain
particular way and it's things that
don't really matter that's gonna be
problematic so for me I think I did a
good job and do a decent job of
discriminating between what actually
matters and what doesn't really matter
and so I'm particularly by the things
that matter and and I the things that
don't really matter okay I'm gonna let
him slide and it's not that big of a
deal and yeah does that take did that
take some effort over the years sure you
know I was a little bit more particular
about things that matter less when I was
younger now I'm a little older a little
bit more mature I grew up a little bit
but now I can look at things I you know
what I'm not gonna worry about that but
these things over here I'm gonna hold
you right but a diet coke you're not
gonna let that slide I hope
we're putting that we're all we're
categorizing them it's obviously the
newest book to the shelves like you said
dichotomy of leadership where does it
sort of fit in with your other books so
you know good gets a good question is
why did you feel the need to write this
considering how thorough you know
extreme ownership is well it's pretty
thorough if you remember the last
chapter and I appreciate you give us a
lot of support for extreme ownership but
that's that's been great it's a great
book the last chapter of extreme
ownerships called the dichotomy of
leadership and you know we hit on it we
hit on the fact that as a leader there
are these dichotomies you and I just
talked about one there's these
dichotomies that are pulling you in
opposite directions and you can see and
as we worked with leaders after Extreme
arch that came out we'd see and probably
are probably my fault probably our fault
for writing extreme ownership and using
the title extreme because people felt
like oh we got to be extreme we got to
be an extreme leader they're like
skateboarding into their conference like
Oh kickflip and then take their knee out
you're like you're 90
stop yeah I've been surance seminars
yeah so so the extremities in leadership
generally aren't that good so the
examples clear examples like as leader
you have to be aggressive right that's
gonna be your default mode you got to
step in and make things happen but at
the same time if you go too far with
that if you're overly aggressive then
you take unnecessary risk and you put
your team at unnecessary risk you put
the mission in unnecessary risk yeah
so you back off of your aggressiveness
but if you back off to too much of your
aggressiveness well then guess what now
you're not being aggressive enough now
you're at the whims of whatever the
situation is and you're not making
anything happen so that's bad so where
do you want to be you want to be
somewhere in the middle another easy one
to to recognize is like talking right a
leader has to communicate a leader has
to talk but can't a leader talk too much
well absolutely
and leader can run their mouth all the
time and now people stop listening
because they're basically crying wolf
about everything that's going on so
that's bad so you back off communicating
so much what if you back off too much
well now you're not communicating enough
and the folks on the frontlines they
don't know what's happening they don't
know what the mission is they don't know
if the goal is and so that's a problem
so where do you want to be you want to
be balanced somewhere and again as we
work with leaders you know cuz I got a
leadership consulting company called
echelon front and we work with all these
different companies all these different
teams and as you work
then we realized that the biggest
problem that leaders have is trying to
find that balance so yeah that's why we
had to write the second book and you
know of course the first book did well
and so the publishers really wanted us
to write a second book really quickly
but we put three years in between the
two books because we wanted to make sure
that we had a subject that was gonna
really hit home and teach leaders
something that's important finding
balance so it's like mister you're kind
of like mr. Miyagi with a buzz cut it's
like find the balance and then you
armbar on them
move on to hear another you talked about
your book Mikey and the Dragons is that
miking the Dragons fighting the Dragons
up and is is this published yet is it
available it's not a it's not published
yet it comes out in November okay and
yeah it's available on Amazon right now
for free the big pre-order but now can
you can you tell me off there the story
with that can we talk about that or no
no it's it's a pretty straightforward
story so I I had an idea for this book
and I actually had one of those moments
where it was pretty cool I woke up in
the middle of the night and wrote the
first half of the book and then I read
it and I was like wow this is good and
another week later I woke up in the
middle night and I wrote the rest of the
book my my daughter and my wife woke up
in the morning and I said hey let me
read you something and they were both
you know my god it was like read it
again who's she was 8 years old inside
she was a leader again and my wife was
looking at me like kind of support she
looked at me like I can't believe you
actually wrote that so yeah which I took
like a compliment you know why can't
believe your daughter orders you around
so now we know admits to who wears the
poem yes trust me so so as I read the
book you know I really liked it I shared
it with a couple of my friends a couple
of my friends kids and everyone was just
nuts about it and it teaches the kids a
very important lesson and so I just
wanted to get this thing out this was in
the summertime I wanted to get this
thing published and publishing is a big
giant well the old school publishing is
what the old school media is you know
it's like well it's this big giant
machine that works in its own way and so
I went to my publisher and I said hey I
got this book you know I want I want to
get this book published by November so
people so the kids can have it for
Christmas let me get in their hands it's
an important book and they were like
well no we're looking at our cycle and
the way thing
work and it's a big you know it's a big
bureaucracy and it's a slow-moving
machine and they said we'll get it
published next cycle it's 14 months away
don't worry about it it'll be great and
I kind of said well no I really want to
do this thing publish can you you know
let's can you help me can we can we make
this happen and and eventually back and
forth back and forth and they were
trying to be accommodating but they just
they just don't have that kind of
maneuverability and finally they just ii
mean there's their quote was there's no
scenario where this book that's
published by november okay I said okay
fair enough so I you know hung up the
phone and then I started my own
publishing company and so you quit and
then created a spite publishing company
perfect that's a good example of a pivot
there and I I'm glad to hear that you
did that because we're actually looking
at hopefully the change my mind book
getting out before Christmas this year I
don't know I don't know that we can
because we have so much work to do but
this is a initially an idea that I had
pitched funny enough back to
conservative publishers many many years
it's about us writing it that's the
issue like we ever like have it all
written the balance probably but yeah
it's about me right we have hundreds of
pages we we took out a stack actually
was it two weeks ago
of just what I had what I had written as
far as like jokes and sketches this year
and I don't know how many thousands of
pages we actually couldn't take it out
of the box it's about 15 16 pages every
single day and that's not including the
change my mind is really about research
and making sure you go back to your
original sources and the point is a long
time ago I didn't have the name change
my mind I pitched it to a conservative
publisher and it was called American
idiots because at this point Green Day
was really popular and they you know I
remember I saw them in Canada they were
chanting American Idiot and I remember I
was the only American there going boh in
Montreal and so I even remember I
designed the cover because I had this
hand with a heart and like a grenade I
remember in mind was a brain basically
the idea that they'd been lobotomized
this idea was describing kind of
different sort of people whose mind you
can change whose minds you can't change
and identifying the difference at the
time we didn't have a lot of the
terminology we do today
point isn't every single publisher
turned it down they did not like it they
were like right-wing people don't do
comedy you know if you find like a
doomsday book where you can sell some
hybrid seeds you let us know
and then there's I will say it was a
small victory this exact same publisher
came up when we got the White House
doing a change my mind secondly
and said we want to do a book deal and I
was like yeah bet you do
so we will you know maybe we will be in
touch though we do need to definitely
have someone at least proofreading it
because man I am
I'm not dyslexic just dumb someone ask
you about this the the Dragons book
Mikey mostly miking the Dragons every
time so like any my could get around
like Matthew and the Dragons it really
sort of um from what I've read from what
I also have that you've sent to me it
talks about sort of the need to be a
hero fort for young boys and overcoming
kind of basic fears and there was a book
I read one time called wild at heart I
don't know if you're familiar with it
but it talks about how every man sort of
young boy needs a damsel to save a
dragon to slay but it's answering that
you talk about overcoming fear what made
you want to write a children's book it
specifically addressing these issues
well the primary thing is I have four
kids you know I have four kids the
oldest one is now 19 years old she's in
college I got a senior in high school I
got a sophomore in high school and I got
a nine year old and so I've seen what
what it does to all I've seen what it
does to kids kids or kids get scared of
things and there's pretty fundamental
principles that you can kind of take
action to overcome your fears and so
that combined with just you know again
diving into human nature all the time on
my podcast and talking about talking
about here as a person and you know I
had to overcome fear you know through my
whole life and you know like I was
scared of the water when I was kid I
ended up becoming a seal well that's
that's that's a good way of overcome
here here you know afraid of heights
okay guess what I jump out of airplanes
hey that's a good way to overcome your
fear of a good result of what we're
coming I was gonna say is it a good way
I mean just throw someone out of a plane
like I'm scared of heights wrong so
there's actually there's actually wigs
actually enough it's called exposure
therapy which is interesting because in
my first kids book I wrote about the kid
who scared of swimming and scared the
water scare swimming and so his uncle
Jake who's a seal who's a navy seal that
stays with him for the summer comes and
says oh you're scared of the water
here's what we're gonna do and he takes
him first to prison and they wait around
in the water then they dunk their heads
in the water then they start walking out
with their chest deep in the water and
then they chart treading water and then
swimming and eventually jumped off the
bridge yes and so I put that in my fur
look like and where I got that from was
my my middle daughter was wanted to be
the star of the school play but she was
scared of scared of the crowds and
scared of performing yeah so I said okay
sing it in front of me okay sing it in
front of me in your mom okay sing it in
front of me and the rest of the family
okay sing it in front of me and the
family and the neighbors and eventually
just build it up where she could get on
stage and she got the lead in the school
play
well I put that around swimming I hope I
stayed a little softer for a glass-like
sing it sing it it's good even drinking
so much white is not that much caffeine
but if you have five of them so when
Jordan Peterson was on my podcast he was
talking about how he had somebody
overcome the fear of needles by starting
to put the needle in the room and then
you put the needle in the in the
bookcase and then you put the picture of
the needle and they hold the needle and
they talk sonido blah blah blah then
they started doing heroin
yeah it's called exposure that's what
it's called it's a real psychological
methodology for people to overcome fear
and anyways so miking the dragon is
about being afraid and what guess what
when you're a little kid you're afraid
of everything and you got to learn to
overcome these fears and so in the book
it's actually a book within a book this
kid the main character Mikey he finds a
book he's actually scared of the book
because there's pictures of
scary-looking dragons in it but he sees
in the book also there's a picture of a
little kid that kind of looks like he
knows what he's doing and so he decides
he's gonna read the book it turns out
that the village or the kingdom inside
the book the King has died he was the
guy that protected the kingdom from the
Dragons now no one wants to face the
Dragons the little prince is like left
everyone's looking at him you gotta face
the Dragons he goes to his dad's war
chest he opens it up he pulls out the
sword the sword said too big for him the
shield he can barely hold up and now
he's getting being more scared I only
sees a note at the bottom of the war
chest he pulls it out it's a note from
his dad and his dad kind of explains to
him how he's gonna overcome these
dragons and the restless' story proceeds
so her daughter was the one who really
liked this and you said reread it and
this is what's interesting because we're
often told that right they sort have to
be separate the books for young boys and
books for young girls and I have to say
listen what's what's what's good for
helping young men learn how to be proper
men is often really good for young women
as well this is one thing I was
interested can you maybe kind of share
some if you have any sort of techniques
or drills that you use to to maintain or
develop sort of the cognitive skills
that you had to develop initially I mean
you know this sort of target
discrimination ah you've talked about an
acquisition in the military
basically it sort of translates to
better decision-making under stress are
there any specific exercises or
techniques that like it is it Lumosity
is Lumosity work questions why get there
I guess there are no techniques or
drills I thought I was I was hoping I
was gonna learn it you don't be given a
grain of wisdom but okay all right
Newton flex to be me yeah the story the
story of the book is actually about my
oldest daughter who came home from
school one day saying I'm stupid I'm
dumb all the other kids are smarter than
me and I said what are you talking about
and she says well I don't know my times
table and everyone else knows him and I
said well how much is he studied him and
she kind of looked at me like what do
you mean study him I said well did you
make flashcards I said you're not just
born knowing the times table so you have
to actually study so we made flashcards
and in an hour she had all the times
tables memorized and so it was my fault
as a parent obviously because I didn't
teach my kid out of study but that
happens with that happens with kids all
the time it happens with them and sports
adapts with them in school and what you
actually have to do is apply yourself
you're not just gonna you're not just
born being able to shoot you know file
shots you have to actually go practice
you're not just born knowing your time
staples are knowing knowing the
Gettysburg Address you actually have to
study them so it's the same thing for me
you know I was kind of a miscreant of a
kid kind of rebellious didn't study
really hard but then when I got in the
military I said to myself okay I want to
win at this game and I realized I had to
learn how to study you can memorize a
bunch of dumb stuff when you're going
through like Navy boot camp well how do
i do that i just i just had to apply
myself and as soon as i started applying
myself I realized oh I can actually I
can actually perform well right as long
as I do as long as I do to work so to
your point about making decisions and
making stressful decisions well what we
do in the SEAL Teams is we we put people
in stressful situations where they learn
how to do some things that we talked
about and in extreme ownership and talk
about the dichotomy in leadership one of
the prime
things to be able to do these to be able
to detox to be able to take a step back
from your emotions and from all that
chaos as a leader take us elevate above
the situation and look around and
actually make a good assessment not
based on the emotions that you're
feeling and not based on the chaos
that's right in front of you you know
but based on what is actually happening
viewed through a logical lens so that's
one thing you can do the other seemingly
difficult - it's easier said that it's
not really really hard
yeah and it's an it's a huge if you can
do it if you learn how to do it it
basically gives you this ultimate power
because what you can see when you're not
engaged is it's just like watching a
football game and everyone's watching
you all why don't they just do this or
that guy should have done that well yeah
you're sitting in the stands or you're
watching it on TV from 14 different
angles the personal the field couldn't
see that well as a leader when you step
back it's a huge advantage to be able to
detach and really assess things from
that from that altitude uh problems
where all the chaos is happening sort of
like telling someone what kind of
questions they should be asking but I do
think I do think so you get the smile
that was jog which is nice we don't see
this so often you got those pearly
whites now here's one thing right
obvious as I watch you as I've listened
to you as I've read you're a passionate
guy right that's kind of that's why
people tell you no get after if you read
the Amazon reviews on the tea which by
the way was delicious people really talk
about being aggressive and getting after
it and being motivated so you're
passionate guy that's one of your I
think that's what makes you magnetic to
a lot of people but when you detach
right so you have to look at it entirely
logically do you sometimes feel as
though or think that you lose one of
your assets which is your passion kind
of your emotive response which sometimes
is an asset because I definitely
struggle with that especially in comedy
it's like men we've got to connect to
this emotionally that's where you that's
where you draw the comedy but then at a
certain point you've also got to make
sure that you get this joke done in time
or this story do you sometimes have to
say alright I need to detach but I also
still have to bring the passion that I
have and find that balance so yeah I'm
gonna actually give you credit back for
your questions again because what you're
talking about is this is this is a
dichotomy of leadership right do you
need to detach yes you absolutely need
to detach can you get too detached yes
you can I don't know if you how much
time you've spent in a workforce in the
labor force but when you go out and you
see a boss that's like an emotionless
person he just he's made
decisions based on the spreadsheet
doesn't communicate doesn't interact
with people nobody wants to follow that
person they lack emotions now so you
can't be on that end of the spectrum and
you're right I couldn't either like I
you you have to show your emotions
because if you show no emotion
whatsoever you're a robot people don't
follow robots the other end of the
spectrum if you're a guy that flies off
the handle and can't control your
emotions well then people think hey if
this guy can't control his own emotions
how's it going to control all this
situation that's happening so where do
you want to be you want to be balanced
somewhere in the middle and you have to
kind of modulate that and you know
here's another funny technique that I
talk about is you know if you come to me
and you're my employee and you come to
me and you're all mad about something
you're flying off the handle I can't
believe this happened I can't believe
this order came in this is ridiculous so
what I need you to do is to attach right
the worst thing I could do is show no
emotion whatsoever the worst thing I
could do is say hey Steven you need to
calm down right all that's gonna do is
make you more inflamed so what I do is I
actually I'm gonna reflect your emotion
but I'm gonna diminish it so I'm not
gonna be as mad as you are but I want to
be on your team if I say hey you need to
calm down and figure out what's wrong
also and I'm not on your team like we're
we're we're antagonistic now and you're
mad at me just about because I'm telling
you to calm but you tell me to calm down
because it's ridiculous that this happen
so what I need to do is say ah Steven
are you serious that's what happened
okay you know what we need to figure out
what's going on down there in the
meantime what can we do to get this
thing resolved right now so I joined
your team I brought you onto my team we
connected because as you pointed out I
showed enough emotions for you to
realize that hey Jocko is on my side
we're together we're a team and now
we're gonna face the Dragons together
and go get this problem solved and that
you know that really translates to
marriage you know I went to marriage
counseling with my wife and I always
recommend that people do the terms they
used was mirroring and then and either
it was a they said defuse the situation
so mirror and defuse or mirror and
deescalate so that I used to happen
where because I I didn't have a temper
problem for a long time and I made sure
I got it under under control my wife
would be really upset about something
and I would make sure to not fly off the
handle and she felt like she wasn't
being listened to so I was like oh okay
you just you just want all Stephens ah
you know thrown a Kiwi through a wall
that actually happened and then you're
like okay let's scale it back a little
bit so you know that's a question since
what would you recommend to sort of an
axis clumps from our animator an editor
here smooth Manny to newly married
couples what big or main piece of advice
would you give would you give to them
would it be the same thing kind of
communicating and mirroring yeah
deescalate is that huge is the huge work
that you and we use that the military to
you know if you're dealing with a crowd
scenario you know rebuild from Iraq and
there would be civilians there civilians
can start getting antsy they can start
getting aggressive yeah and you can
escalate it if you if you show them that
back or you can deescalate it and let
them know hey you know we're we're firm
but you know this isn't a problem so
de-escalation is a huge part of it and
and to what you just said again you're
doing great how do you do that though
really quick for people like there's
some steps someone's might say okay
de-escalation but how do I do it
is it okay mat mirroring the emotion and
then offering a solution of those kind
of the first two steps yeah well to your
point you don't want to mirror the exact
emotion so if your wife is screaming and
yelling you don't wanna scream and yell
back at her what you want to do is you
want to show her enough like concern and
emotion yourself but at the same time
start ratcheting it down so that she'll
match you and then you can take it a
little bit lower and a little bit
lowering so you've got a calm situation
where you can actually communicate
intelligently and you know it's the same
thing you know if you're dealing with
civilians that are getting rowdy well if
you just start punching people or you
know striking them with a baton that
what's gonna happen they're gonna resist
more in many cases they're gonna resist
more and then you now you have escalated
the situation it turns bad for everyone
whereas if you hey hey you know what can
you back off you try and communicate
with people you try and show them that
you're a human being you know we would
have Arabic speakers with us that we
would say hey tell them to calm down or
we and we could learn a little bit of
Arabic so we can at least say hey it's
okay we're not gonna be here long we're
leaving in a minute hey sorry about you
know
sorry we're here just that kind of thing
enough to de-escalate and and so yeah
it's opening up communications and
talking for the the question about
newlyweds and marriage I mean first of
all take ownership right we need the
minute you start blaming your your
spouse for
whatever you're gonna lose your like
that's not a good situation
so take ownership of what the problems
are and then figure out what you can do
to get them fixed that's number one
number two stay balanced what you just
described don't be the guy that flies
off the handle but don't be the guy that
has no emotions you want to be balanced
you want to be somewhere in the middle
you want to pay attention to what your
spouse is saying so that you can kind of
mirror it without overreacting and
getting crazy yeah those are those are
two good points for for marriage man you
know I've been married for for 21 years
you know in a job that has a divorce
rate of about 90% so not must be
something special to lock down a stud
muffin like you for 21 years
or she's got it you know her own issues
exactly yeah you're both the only ones
who would take each other let me ask you
this I know you usually avoid and this
is again from from Manny anything it's
sort of a divisive or or or political
often but do you worry today having so
many kids you're a virile man by the way
I'll give you that so many kids raised
in a generation where not only the first
amendment but the second Amendment
rights Nora roading as you write in
these books is that her does ever occur
to you ever get worried about what kind
of world they'll grow up in I would say
yeah I mean I definitely look at some of
the erosion of some of these rights that
and but here's the thing and I got asked
this by ben shapiro the other day you
know he he said hey on a team we were
talking about leadership he says on a
team isn't it don't you need to have a
common cause and I said yeah of course
you need to have a common cause and he
said do you think we have a common cause
here in America and I said well yeah I
think you know people in America
generally they want to have you know
they want to have a good economy they
want to do a good job and you know he
came back and said you know I don't know
if I'm just more pessimistic than you
but I don't know is I don't think we
have a common like a common cause in
America anymore I think there's people
that want something completely different
than what I want yeah and and what I
said to him was I you know and I mean
he's kind of like you I guess you guys
are in the same space as far as just
being inundated with with the extremes
right the extremists on the left are
just coming at you all the time and what
I told them was I listen you hear that
stuff all day long
I said I work with companies all over
America in in in every city in America
in towns in America and the normal
people in America they're not that's not
the way those the way the extreme left
and the extreme right those people
aren't normal they're not the majority
are they the loudest without a question
they're the loudest people but are they
the ones that are going to take over no
they're not going to take over and
there's a big I mean the vast majority
of Americans are what they want to do
they want to have a good economy they
want to do a good job they want to build
a business they want to take care of
their kids they want the kids to have a
better future than them they want to own
a house that's what they want
yeah and so and when these extremists on
either side really truly start to
infringe on the normal people in America
the normal people in America aren't
gonna stand for it yeah they're good
they hey look you want to pick sit over
there and run your mouth on this side or
run your mouth on this side
whatever we're you know we're over here
where you know we're doing we're
actually working is what we're doing
we're not going to let going to a job
and going to our kids game and that's a
weirder that's what most of America most
of America is not going to protest and
and most of America is not like sitting
online you know sending tweets to bother
you know steven crowder that's not what
they're doing now most though I am on
the ISIS kill list so that's what I
found out it's a very long list now I'm
sure you know it doesn't really mean
anything like I was but then the FBI
comes like there's but then there's a
separate list that's look like you're on
that too so you know what he made yes
yes I've made the top when you when you
paint Mohamed as Bob Ross and a parody
they don't have a lot of tolerance for
it no I think you're right but we were
only I think with Heller DC either one
or two votes away on the Supreme Court
from losing private firearm ownership
period so it is sometimes it's a very
very thin line so I would agree with was
Ben in the sense that I really you're
saying most Americans are not
represented necessarily in the media
that being said when I look at an entire
political platform and I come from
Canada right so we actually had mike
Ward here he's been fine and people been
put in jail for speech in Canada this is
the only place where it exists the
United States freedom speech doesn't
exist anywhere else it can go away
really quickly and that's one thing that
really concerns me you know obviously
for
future generations but um I'm sure your
kids will do fine let me go back to
unless I did you have something you're
about to say just just just where we
started out this conversation for me
like there's things that matter there's
things that don't matter there's lots of
little things that don't matter and
there is a fine line between you know in
the political environment that we live
in there's a lot of people that are
barking and jumping up and down whatever
that I don't care about I'm not gonna
sit there and bark and play the games
with them but you know clearly there are
there are things that are important that
do matter I mean the first amendment
second man I mean those constitutional
rights that we have obviously they're
they're hugely important to me
and I as we if those lines ever get
crossed and it's gonna be like okay well
we're not going to allow that like we're
not gonna stand for that and I think
that's the way a vast majority of
Americans feel yeah I do think that's
the way the majority of Americans feel
unfortunately sometimes that's not
necessarily represent let me ask you
this what for you
I would imagine discipline is a little
bit different than for a lot of people
and I've learned this kind of managing
different people I am hyper ly organized
I'm up early by nature that's kind of
how I am which is not very typical of
someone who's a comment kind of into
creative realm so I'm a bit of a
dichotomy but for you I would imagine
discipline to me discipline is something
that's hard discipline is doing
something consistently even if you don't
want to do it once the excitement is
worn off right so for you discipline
probably working out isn't as hard I
would imagine as being disciplined about
rest being disciplined about you know
not getting like we talked about overly
jazzed about something learning to
detach would you say that's kind of a
discipline and a skill that is more
difficult for you and how do you how do
you hone that in because that's
something I've always I've always
struggled with is not overdoing it not
burning out well for me I think it's
pretty obvious when I'm when I'm getting
smoked which I can do to myself I mean I
can get to a point where like I'm
working all the time and when I know
that I've kind of when I'm done like
when I get on airplanes I get so much
work done because I either get worked on
our asleep but when I get on airplanes I
usually get worked on because I don't
get the the Wi-Fi so I can just write or
I can just work I can prepare to do a
podcast I can read something for a
podcast and I travel a lot so
this is pretty common and when I know
that I'm smoke haze when I get on an
airplane and I've got you know a four
hour or five hour flight and my mind is
just going you just need to just not do
anything right so you know what I do I
mean this happened to me you know
probably five or six months ago I got on
board and I watched Zoolander that's
fine I know you really when you started
I thought about to say Xanadu and I was
like he's gay but Zoolander's fine yeah
so
and I sat there and watched him we've
got to and and and had a good laugh but
yeah why did I do that well it's because
at that point I realized okay your your
brain is just toast right now you don't
feel like doing this and and and this is
coming from someone normally when my
brain says you don't feel like doing
this I'm like okay really really that's
pathetic and I'm gonna crush you because
you even had that thought in your brain
yeah but when I hear that you know it's
just I wrote about my book just when it
goes Freedom Field Manual like when you
don't want to do something that's fine
don't do it but don't do it tomorrow
right like I don't feel like working out
today cool I don't feel like working out
today I'm still gonna work out if I
still don't feel like working out
tomorrow that I won't work out right and
that's kind of way the way and with
everything like writing you know I read
a bunch of books in order to write a
book you got to sit down in front of a
computer and you gotta type words which
is not exactly fun now so there's a lot
of days where I got you know what I can
just put it off till tomorrow no I won't
I'm gonna do it today I'm gonna do today
I'm gonna make it happen
and then if I really need a break and I
still need a break tomorrow then I'll
take a break but right now I'm gonna get
it done you can't negotiate with you
know the terrorists in your brain that's
trying to tell you to be weak that's you
know that's a really good point I
actually just had this conversation with
my wife yesterday you know the old
Churchill quote you can't rash was it
you can't negotiate with a tiger when
your head is in its mouth yeah and and
you want being able to make the decision
to take a break I think is what's
important as opposed to basically being
brought to your knees so funny you'd
mention movies for me I can't watch a
film because I'm Washington I'm
analyzing the shot place when I'm
looking at the lenses no okay I see what
they did here I see the writing it's the
timing in the pacing so I just try and
shut off on a plane but how funny would
it be if you got in a plane and wrote a
whole book and it was on Google Docs and
because didn't have the Wi-Fi it was
totally
I've done not be funny at all actually
medium it was funny to me it happened to
me and everyone here had a huge laugh
wasn't a full book but it was it was 15
pages or so yeah it be be very leery of
the Google Docs if you're not on the
Wi-Fi I think that's that's really
helpful advice and III appreciate that's
something that a lot of people struggle
with a lot of people struggle with in
training a lot of people struggle with
is is is burnout and I always want to
talk with people a lot of young people I
know you know what this advice isn't for
you yet it's kind of like black with
jiu-jitsu it's like you know what you're
not at the point where you need to worry
about overtraining you know you need to
worry about getting your basics down
first but once you reach a certain point
it's it becomes even more of a concern
okay
the website is I want to make sure I got
this right Jacko podcast.com that
economy a leadership of leadership is a
newest book Amazon is there anywhere
else where people should be looking for
it yeah well everywhere Barnes and Noble
Amazon wherever you buy books that's
available
yeah Barnes and Noble though they should
have they should have quit a long time
ago there's a Barnes & Noble around here
that's a Barnes & Noble cafe they don't
even have any books so that tells you
where paperback is going and then the
other book you said you can pre-order on
Amazon is Mikey and the Dragons right
the Dragons Mike and the Dragons alright
thank you so much Chuck I appreciate you
coming back really enjoyed the tea
actually I'm gonna ask mani for some
more of that and hope to have you back
soon man the video where I would tell
you if you like this video to subscribe
only that doesn't mean anything anymore
because it doesn't esse Sara Lee appear
in your subscription feed so this is
about the point where you know I would
tell you to hit the notification bell
but that doesn't mean anymore because he
hit it nothing happens so the only
option you have is to join my club a lot
of credit calm slash mug Club that way
we don't lose contact with you or at
least bookmark this YouTube page but I'm
pretty sure that Google will find a way
to screw with your bookmarks and switch
it to Samantha B and CNN so just join
mug club unless you want us to go away
and of course all the Bangladeshi
children who will die as a result
because they help us with developing
costs